[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis guten abend und
herzlich willkommen alles wichtige vom
sport hat norbert lehmann
schauen wir auf die großen themen des
tages im vorstoss zum ferienende als
erstes bundesland macht
schleswig-holstein bald auch kindern und
jugendlichen an den schulen impfangebot
wie die spenden helfen für die
notversorgung in den hochwassergebieten
haben auch zdf zuschauer schon viele
millionen euro zur verfügung gestellt
und erfolg für deutsches duo jonathan
rommelmann und jason osborne holen im
doppel zweier silber in den ersten
bundesländern gehen die sommerferien
jetzt zu ende und die große frage ist
was ist mit corona impfung für kinder
und jugendliche schleswig holstein will
dafür mobile impft teams an schulen
schicken brandenburg und berlin an
berufsschulen so soll ein impfangebot
gemacht werden
zurzeit sind in der eu zwei impfstoffe
für kinder und jugendliche zugelassen
der von bayern tech pfizer und der von
moderner in deutschland ist die ständige
impfkommission aber sehr zurückhaltend
nur 12 bis 17 jährige mit besonderen
risiko wie vorerkrankungen sollten
geimpft werden und wenn dann mit dem
bayern tag im stoff einer hebestreit
berichtet gut die hälfte der menschen in
deutschland sind vollständig gegen
korona geimpft allerdings erst zehn
prozent der minderjährigen angesichts
der starken ausbreitung der delta
variante precht schleswig holstein zum
beginn des neuen schuljahres voran 250
schulen im norden sollen mobile im teams
anrollen
wir sprechen über ein freiwilliges
angebot das wir ab dem 19
august in den schulräumen ermöglichen
die infektion wird durch die
kassenärztliche vereinigungen
durchgeführt nicht durch die schulen
kinder ab zwölf können sich den
impfstoff von brillanter kaiser
verabreichen lassen viele eltern fühlen
sich überrumpelt befürchten gruppenzwang
in der schule werden dann auch dinge
diskutiert man möglicherweise entsteht
ein eindruck von wegen ja ich impfe mich
warum nimmst du dich nicht und eltern
fühlen sich vielleicht auch da in ihrer
entscheidungsfreiheit eingeschränkt
werden familien drohen diskussionen denn
ab 14 jahren können kinder selbst
entscheiden ob sie sich impfen lassen
die ständige impfkommission hat noch
fragen ist der impfstoff wirklich sicher
gelockt und dazu muss man sagen die
zulassungsstudien mit ja sehr wenig
kämpften kinder lässt eine aussage dazu
nicht zu kurz bevor die kinder wieder in
die schule gehen wächst der druck auf
die stiko sich klar zu positionieren
die sollen mal ein bisschen in die gänge
kommen nur zu sagen wir haben nicht
genug daten wir können dazu uns nicht
äußern ist angesichts der dringlichkeit
der lage keine gut genug gehalten
frühestens in zwei wochen will die stiko
eine empfehlung abgeben vielleicht noch
rechtzeitig genug bevor die impf teams
in die schule kommen
viele die ab dem ersten august aus dem
urlaub zurück kommen müssen sich nun
offenbar auf corona testen lassen
die regierungskoalition soll sich auch
verschärfungen an den grenzen in
richtung deutschland geeinigt haben
demnach sollen einreisende einen test
vorlegen
ausnahmen gelten für genesene und
vollständig geimpft
die entsprechende verordnung soll
demnach morgen im kabinett beschlossen
werden
theo koll in unserem hauptstadtstudio
was bedeutet das jetzt konkret nun ganz
konkret das ab sonntag alle
reiserückkehrer im test vorweisen müssen
oder alternativ den nachweis einer
vollständigen impfung oder den nachweis
von corona gewesen zu sein das gilt
nicht nur wie bisher schon für
flugreisende sondern egal mit welchem
verkehrsmittel man unterwegs ist also ob
mit auto bahn oder schiff für die
sogenannten virusvarianten gebiete also
beispielsweise länder wie brasilien oder
südafrika gilt die testpflicht dann auch
für geimpfte und genießen darauf haben
sich heute die beteiligten ministerien
geeinigt umstritten war dabei
offensichtlich auf eine verordnung
ausreicht oder ob es eine
gesetzesänderung braucht das hat man
heute ausgeräumt jetzt geht die
verordnung noch heute in ein sogenanntes
umlaufverfahren aller ministerien so
dass die regelung dann morgen als vom
kabinett beschlossen gilt und ab sonntag
greift vielen dank für diese
einschätzung theo koll allein ein blick
ins supermarktregal zeigt die inflation
ist stark gestiegen und das heißt es
wird teurer
so legten die verbraucherpreise im juli
um 3,8 prozent zu im vergleich zum
vorjahresmonat so das statistische
bundesamt zum ersten mal seit 13 jahren
liegt die inflation damit über drei
prozent valerie haller für uns an der
frankfurter börse
valerie woran liegt das das liegt an
verschiedenen faktoren ein
entscheidender ist die mehrwertsteuer
die bundesregierung hatte sie ja zur
entlastung der wirtschaft im zweiten
halbjahr 20 20 gesenkt nun werden diese
aktuellen preise mit denen damals
gesenkten verglichen ja und dadurch
ergibt sich ganz automatisch ein
preisanstieg aber nicht nur das
tatsächlich ist auch vieles teurer
geworden manches sogar deutlich
nachdem corona preiseinbruch besonders
benzin und öl um 11,6 prozent und
nahrungsmittel plus 4,3 prozent das ende
der fahnenstange ist wohl noch nicht
erreicht experten rechnen mit einer
inflationsrate zum jahresende von
zeitweise nahezu fünf prozent
entspannung ist aber vermutlich in sicht
im kommenden jahren der mehrwertsteuer
effekt wieder verschwindet auch müssten
für eine längerfristig höhere inflation
die löhne anziehen und dafür gibt es
bisher noch kaum anzeichen
vielen dank valerie haller gute zahlen
vom arbeitsmarkt weniger menschen sind
arbeitslos und das ist außergewöhnlich
im sommermonat juli laut bundesagentur
für arbeit waren zwei millionen 590.000
menschen ohne arbeit das sind 320.000
menschen weniger als noch vor einem jahr
die quote sinkt dadurch leicht auf jetzt
5,6 prozent zwei wochen ist das
hochwasser in rheinland-pfalz und
nordrhein-westfalen her wie so eine
katastrophe künftig verhindert werden
kann ist längst wahlkampfthema die
grünen schlagen nun ein bundesweiten
klima vorsorgefonds vor über 25
milliarden euro
in den flutgebieten selbst geht es um
konkrete sorgen gerade kann das haus
wieder aufgebaut werden und zahlt die
versicherung torge bode war mit einem
bausachverständigen unterwegs es ist
kein leichter ortsterminen schneiden für
schadensregulierer wieder schluss und
sein team der boden voller öligem
schlamm eine giftige mischung die seit
zwei wochen ins mauerwerk eingesickert
ist wohl ein totalschaden
wir sind hier nicht groß
in diesem keller kam ein mensch im
hochwasser ums leben die angehörigen in
trauer
trotzdem muss der mann von der
versicherung seinen job machen
wir müssen sagen dass aufgrund des öls
hier nimmt man ein problem besteht und
dass hier ebenfalls im worst case auch
sein kann dass das gebäude nicht zu
sanieren ist und abzureißen ist der
nächste termin
was hier noch zu retten ist ungewiss 23
jahre hat maren rettinger mit ihrer
familie in diesem denkmalgeschützten
fachwerkhaus in schleiden gewohnt als
das wasser kam war die familie im urlaub
das haus elementar versichert jetzt
hoffen sie dass die versicherung schnell
zahlt denn machen rettinger träumt von
einem neustart
wenn ich das okay kriege da auch sehr
frei mit umgehen zu können ja dann ist
es so dass wir dann gleich nochmal druck
machen als familie und sagen ja das ist
unser eltern eine abschlagszahlung kann
die dusche und sofort anbieten wie viel
genau das ist wird nicht verraten
in der hochwasserregion hat allein die
generali versicherung in den letzten
tagen rund 3000 fälle abgearbeitet
wie hoch der schaden insgesamt ist lässt
sich noch gar nicht beziffern
diese flut und diese menge an schäden
das ist wirklich eine herkulesaufgabe
für jeden fall sicher viele der
betroffenen werden allerdings auf den
großteil ihrer kosten sitzen bleiben
denn nicht einmal die hälfte der
geschädigten war gegen hochwasser
versichert wenn sie den menschen im
hochwassergebiet helfen wollen das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe hat ein
spendenkonto eingerichtet
die iban lautet de 65 104 106 100 104
106 100 stichwort zdf hochwasser und
weitere informationen finden sie unter
spenden punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 8 190 rund 60 millionen euro sind
bisher durch die zdf spendenaktion
gesammelt worden und wir zeigen ihnen
jetzt wie durch dieses geld den
betroffenen menschen in den flutgebieten
erst einmal mit dem allernötigsten
geholfen wird
angela app hat berichtet unermüdlich
arbeiten die menschen im
katastrophengebiet daran ihren alltag
irgendwie in den griff zu bekommen
doch noch immer fehlt es am nötigsten
strom etwa in ahrweiler hat das deutsche
rote kreuz einen großen generator mit
lichtmast aufgestellt 30 haushalte in
dieser wohnsiedlung können jetzt auch
endlich bohrhammer und bautrockner
betreiben
wunderbar so dass ich sogar die
spendengelder kommen bei den menschen an
man hat wirklich das gefühl dass das
dass die leute in deutschland auf uns
gucken und mit uns die
hilfsorganisationen kümmern sich hier um
das was die menschen täglich brauchen
warmes wasser duschen wichtig auch zum
schutz gegen krankheiten denn staub und
schlamm sind von heizöl und fäkalien
kontaminiert in einer schule in sinzig
gibt es spenden finanziert für flutopfer
und helfer jeden tag ein warmes
mittagessen
das rad linie mit schinken sahnesoße
inflation
das sind circa 650 portionen die
gemeinsame mahlzeit auch eine
gelegenheit sich über das erlebte
auszutauschen stromaggregate durch
container essensausgabe nur drei
beispiele von vielen projekten die mit
hilfe der spendengelder finanziert
werden
wir haben men und women power um das mal
so zu sagen aber ohne spendengelder wäre
es gar nicht möglich um die menschen
hier vor ort mit dem nötigsten einfach
zu versorgen
der wiederaufbau der ortschaften im
aartal wird sicher jahre dauern
die menschen hier hoffen dass die
großzügige spendenbereitschaft noch
lange anhält
zwei tage nach der gewaltigen explosion
in einer leverkusener
müllverbrennungsanlage sind drei weitere
opfer tot geborgen worden
die zahl der toten hat sich damit auf
fünf erhöht zwei menschen werden immer
noch vermisst
die analyse der stoffe die mit der
rauchwolke in die wohngebiete getragen
wurden dauert an
ergebnisse werden erst ende der woche
erwartet die stadt empfiehlt anwohner
innen bis auf weiteres kein obst oder
gemüse aus dem garten zu essen da
facebook nutzer und nutzerinnen sperren
die hasserfüllte kommentare schreiben
dazu hat der bundesgerichtshof heute ein
urteil gefällt
konkret ging es um rassistische äußerung
und das gericht entschied facebook darf
die beiträge nicht löschen und die
konnten nicht vorübergehend sperren ohne
den nutzern die möglichkeit geben sich
dazu zu äußern
christian decker mit den details wann
ist die grenze zur hassrede
überschritten eindeutig bei diesen
kommentar über menschen mit
migrationshintergrund sagt facebook 2018
diese goldstücke können nur eines morden
clown randalieren und ganz wichtig nie
arbeiten facebook löschte den kommentar
wegen des vorwurfs der hassrede auch
wenn es keine straftat war
der bundesgerichtshof hat nun
entschieden facebook hätte nicht einfach
so löschen dürfen die rechte der
nutzerinnen und nutzer seien nicht
ausreichend beachtet worden
daher muss sich facebook verpflichten
einträge eines nutzers zu löschen aber
den nutzer dann nachträglich darüber zu
informieren
und wenn facebook beabsichtigt eine
nutzer vollständig zu löschen muss der
nutzer das recht haben sich dazu zu
äußern
facebook reagiert auf das urteil wir
werden die entscheidung des
bundesgerichtshofs sorgfältig prüfen um
sicherzustellen dass wir weiterhin
effektiv gegen hass rede in deutschland
vorgehen können
netzaktivist markus beckedahl begrüßt
die entscheidung
bisher bestand facebook immer auf der
position dass man als unternehmen mit
seinen gemeinschafts regeln einfach mal
den öffentlichen diskurs bestimmen
könnte wie man wolle allerdings haben es
hier mit einem markt dominanten fast
monopolartigen unternehmens zu tun was
eine neue öffentlichkeit darstellt und
der bundesgerichtshof hat heute die
rechte der nutzerinnen gegenüber dem
unternehmen gestärkt das gericht musste
alle belange berücksichtigen
der bgh hat ja eine abwägung vorgenommen
zwischen den interessen von facebook auf
der einen seite und der meinungsfreiheit
auf der anderen seite und die ist bei
facebook bisher zu kurz gekommen sagt
der bgh
der us konzern muss zukünftig seine
nutzungsbedingungen wohl ändern
blicken wir in die türkei wo in mehreren
provinzen heftige waldbrände wüten unter
anderem in der region um antalya
mehrere menschen kamen in den flammen
ums leben dutzende wurden verletzt
die feuer dort waren in manavgat östlich
von antalya ausgebrochen
die touristenorte sind derzeit außer
gefahr doch an anderen stellen in der
provinz kämpfen einsatzkräfte weiter
gegen die flammen
ihr brase berichtet die flammen kamen
sehr schnell und brachten tod und
zerstörung angefacht durch starken wind
dieser bauer versucht verzweifelt die
löschfahrzeuge zu seinen ställen zu
dirigieren
leute das da drüben sind meine kühe und
pferde dürfte das ist alles meine tiere
viele kommen in den flammen um
zahlreiche häuser brennen nieder wir
hätten nicht gedacht dass das feuer so
schnell bei uns sein wird dachten wir
schaffen es noch aber in der nacht ist
unser haus dann abgebrannt wir konnten
vor lauter rauch die hand nicht mehr vor
augen sehen wir haben nur unsere kinder
geschnappt und sind gerade die touristen
strände in der region manavgat sind
einige kilometer entfernt dort bestehe
keine gefahr heißt es auch viele
deutsche machen hier gerade urlaub wir
machen unseren sorgen bringt wenn da
mehr wegen den menschen hier und weniger
als tourist wir sehen was die
feuerwehrmänner hierfür unmenschliche
leistungen momentan erbringen
und man muss auch sehen das feuer ist
hintermannschaft als juristen gibt
weiter westlich von manavgat aber an der
küste von marmaris und bodrum lodern die
flammen nahe der touristen hotels die
ersten besucher werden evakuiert die
leitzentrale in ankara registriert
bislang 53 brände in verschiedenen
provinzen weil viele feuer zeitgleich
ausbrachen vermutet die polizei in
einigen fällen brandstiftung und hat
ermittlungen eingeleitet
die meisten brände sind gelöscht oder
unter kontrolle
für entwarnung aber ist es noch zu früh
und wir schauen zu olympia in tokio und
norbert da gab es ja auch heute wieder
medaillen für das deutsche team zweimal
bronze und es gab die erste medaille für
die ruderer jonathan rommelmann und
jason osborne haben silber geholt die
erste olympische medaille für
deutschland im
leichtgewichts-doppelzweier erschöpft
aber glücklich die beiden deutschen
jonathan rommelmann und jason osborne im
leichten doppelzweier hinter dem
favorisierten boot aus irland verpassten
die ruderer nur knapp olympisches gold
dennoch gehen sie mit der silbermedaille
in die olympischen geschichtsbücher ein
denn es ist die erste deutsche medaille
überhaupt in dieser bootsklasse der
männer seit der olympia-premiere 1996 in
atlanta
wir sind einfach superglücklich und über
stolz darauf wie das rennen gelaufen ist
wir haben heute alles in die waagschale
geworfen
bronze im kanadier ging an andrea herzog
die dritte medaille für die deutschen
slalomkanuten herzog für ein sicheres
und souveränes rennen
silber holte die britin mallory franklin
olympisches gold für die top favoritin
jessica fox aus australien
judo weltmeisterin anna maria wagner
gewinnt die bronzemedaille gegen die
frühere wm-dritte kalima an thomas
gruber es ist die erste olympische
medaille für die frauen im
kopien der deutsche olympische sportbund
zieht aus dem eklat um rat sportdirektor
patrick moster nun doch konsequenzen
einen tag nach seiner rassistischen
entgleisungen muss muster von den
olympischen spielen in tokio abreisen
und der radsport-weltverband
suspendierte muster vorläufig doppel
weltmeister florian wellbrock hat die
zweite medaille für die deutschen
beckenschwimmer knapp verpasst der
23-jährige belegte über 800 meter
freistil den vierten platz
alexander schwere steht im olympischen
tennis halbfinale und trifft morgen auf
den weltranglisten-ersten novak djokovic
im viertelfinale bezwang deutschlands
bester tennisspieler den franzosen
jeremy chardy mit 6 zu 4 und 6 zu 1 ein
nie gefährdeter und äußerst dominanter
sieg des hamburgers und ein echter
halbfinal krimi im tischtennis dimitrij
ovtcharov unterlag weltmeister ma long
aus china nur ganz knapp mit drei zu
vier sätzen
die ballwechsel in diesem halbfinale
spektakulär oft schroff zeigt seine
ganze klasse und startet eine aufholjagd
nach 0 2 satzrückstand immer wieder
zwingt ma long zu fehlern das erste
olympia finale für einen deutschen
tischtennisspieler zum greifen nah doch
am ende dieses packenden krimis muss
sich oft schroff erneut geschlagen geben
die neunzehnte niederlage im 19
gegen ma long oft schroff kann noch
bronze gewinnen
er trifft am freitag im kleinen finale
auf linie aus taiwan
und das was vom sport dankeschön norbert
und wir schauen noch aufs wetter für
morgen kündigen sich unwetter im süden
deutschlands an die einzelheiten hat
gleich ist intelli für sie um 21 45
begrüßt die claus kleber im
heute-journal und wir sagen auf
wiedersehen machen sie es gut
[Musik]
sogenannte und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter ein neues tief nähert sich uns
und erst einmal ist es über den
britischen inseln
aber es ist verbunden mit diesem
regengebiet hier über den alpen und aus
den alpen herauswachsen morgen
nachmittag dann heftige gewitter im
unwetter bereich mit starkregen und
hagel und dazu auch noch sturmböen
wir schauen erst mal in die kommende
nacht uns da gibt es im norden regen
stark starker wind aus südwest teils
stürmische ansonsten klar des
grösstenteils auf im osten und im süden
osten dazu temperaturen nach westen um 9
grad und in bayern bis 14 grad morgen
tagesverlauf viel sonnenschein und dann
ab dem nachmittag und in den
abendstunden von den alpen heraus dann
heftige gewitter teils mit unwetter
starkregen hagel und sturm ist dabei und
im norden
da schaut es weiter dazwischen bleibt es
größtenteils trocken mit temperaturen im
süden bis 29 grad 20 grad in
schleswig-holstein die kommenden tage am
samstag gibt es im süden heftige
gewitter das geht den dauerregen über
und dann am sonntag vor allem im süden
deutschlands dann dauerregen und
deutlich kühler
ein schöner abend